oi gente tô bom nome
ali eu sou editor e diretor de cinema e
eu sou graduando na universidade federal
do rio de janeiro na escola de
comunicação e eu sou uma pessoa transita
binária
é a gente vai falar sobre questões de
gênero e sexualidade é um tema muito
novo e muito polêmico então tudo que eu
falar aqui é muito fluido e essas
definições variam muito dependendo de
convencer está falando é eu vou falar
baseado na minha experiência enquanto
dentro do ativismo e dentro da teoria
acadêmica que eu tenho algum contato
primeiro vou falar de quatro aspectos
que as pessoas costumam confundir muito
e eles são independentes
é o primeiro deles a identidade de
gênero e identidade de gênero a como a
pessoa se identifica se ela é homens
sala mulher para uma pessoa não me na
área dentro do novo binário tem diversos
gêneros atração sexual e romântico quais
gêneros as pessoas se identificam ou
elas podem também se identificam por
quais genes das pessoas se atraem e se
relacionam e tem pessoas também que não
bom se atrair nenhum gênero ou por menos
duas pessoas as secções expressão de
gênero é como a pessoa se comporta e os
pronomes que ela prefere e à estética
que ela tem e o genital
essa pessoa tem sistema reprodutor
varian no sistema reprodutor testicular
da pessoa em ter sexo é dentro dentro
destes quatro aspectos a gente vive numa
sociedade que tem que é hétero
esse compulsório de gênero são pessoas
que não são trânsito então uma sociedade
que automaticamente a solução se
e entre elas as pessoas que nascem com
pênis são automaticamente homens
as pessoas que nascem cuba são
automaticamente mulher e dentro disso os
homens vão gostar de mulheres e as
mulheres vão gostar de homem mas a gente
sabe que apesar dessa norma e apesar
dessa tentativa de da sociedade de
englobar as pessoas dentro de si binário
a gente tem pessoas mais diversas
possíveis a gente vai ter mulheres
barbadas a gente vai ter homens com base
na a gente vai ter pessoas andrógenas
pessoas não binárias mulheres masculinas
que gostam de homens
e esse não é o problema
não há problemas pessoas serem
diferentes o problema e se essa
sociedade que engloba as pessoas dentro
desses dois lugares
mesmo as pessoas que não são trânsito
mesmo as pessoas que tenham que se
comportam dentro de si binário ela sofre
incômodo é aquilo a que eu mostrei
aquele binário acho que tá mais pra isso
do que uma coisa tão regrada
[Música]
vocês podem perceber que até agora não
falei sobre cirurgias e as pessoas até
uma pessoa sttrans da cirurgia e o que
não é verdade tem pessoas trans que não
acontecesse humanizar não vão querer
fazer cirurgias e tem pessoas quase a
grande maioria das pessoas se gêneros
podem surgir seja estética seja por
qualquer motivo
mulheres se gêneros ou seja que não são
tranqüilas colocam silicone homem se
gêneros tiram peito porque começa a
crescer fazem reposição hormonal e isso
é um problema
o problema é as pessoas trans que
decidem fazer cirurgia sem patologia
usadas há o problema das pessoas trans
tem que ter lado pra fazer essas
cirurgias e terem que passar por
processos muitas vezes
esse processo em que são martinho
utilizadores é todo esse binarismo que
eu expliquei ele causa problemas pessoas
desviantes
esses problemas são desde abusos do
bullying até morte
as mulheres transe travestis têm
expectativa de vida de 35 anos no brasil
a gente tem medo de frequentar banheiros
e ea gente sofre agressões diariamente é
ano passado
eu ganhei o edital da riofilme um filme
com teclado e eu fiz questão de chamar
pessoas trans para trabalhar era um
filme sobre o cartunista transgénero
dentro da equipe do site todas as
pessoas eram transam mulheres que são
pessoas que têm dificuldade para entrar
no mercado de trabalho
nisso a a universidade tem um papel que
é fundamental a outra pessoa sttrans
para dentro delas ea dani vai falar mais
sobre isso
para complementar um pouco tudo que o
cara depois aqui eu queria discutir de
maneira geral mais pontual a importância
da representatividade a nossa sociedade
a forma como ela se constitui na nossa
sociedade contemporânea capitalista ela
decide e determina quem é o outro e isso
começa na formação da nossa sociedade é
nos primórdios da formação da sociedade
que explora o capital de outro e começa
com a identificação do corpo feminino
como aquele que é o padrão o parâmetro
do outro da alteridade e à parte um
pouco disso a gente pensar um pouco no
traçado da história da alteridade e da
objetificação e da é do juiz do
silenciamento da opressão do outro é a
partir desse movimento de identificação
no feminino da identidade feminina como
o outro como alteridade negativa que a
gente pode recuperar o movimento de
opressão geral
então é a nossa sociedade caminha um
pouco à parte disso é a sociedade
capitalista que prescinde nem
prescindirá aliás da necessidade de
exploração do outro de colocação do
outro no lugar de explorado vai utilizar
dessa autoridade negativa para se
efetivar para se constituir é claro que
nada nem aí com o movimento orgânico e
vivo da sociedade nada é gratuito e há
muita é resistente os movimentos de
resistência ao longo da história são
demais são enormes e são às vezes muito
rigorosos na uma sociedade complexa como
a nossa é que tem o vigor de um
liberalismo pelo menos um liberalismo
teórico a gente vive a contradição do
fascismo né
quando as nossas convicções liberais nos
leva empoderar os segmentos oprimidos e
marginalizados
o par sismo com as suas plantas maioria
com a idéia de que o outro deve ser
reprimido de que o outro errado com seus
preconceitos estereótipos surge para
impedir esses avanços nem tão é a gente
percebe que os movimentos de retrocesso
de contenção dos avanços das dos
segmentos marginalizado está sempre
ligado a uma reafirmação de estereótipo
que se quer negar
então quando nós pessoa sttrans
começamos a ocupar determinado esporte
na sociedade de determinados espaços
imediatamente a que todos aqueles
estereótipos são acionadas outra nos
vencer para nos silenciar e para nos
animar o direito da nossa plena e
efetiva é cidadania
então por isso que é tão importante que
nós localizamos o que nós somos e que
nós ocupamos um espaço na nossa
sociedade que nós de fato eh eh eh eh
revertamos e de certa maneira consigamos
ocupar o espaço que não é tirado que nos
é negado
é isso aí foi muito importante do épo
o tempo que há homens e mulheres
transexuais ocupassem espaço de postos
muito ligados à manutenção de um padrão
de feminino ou masculino e hoje em dia
já não é mais assim ea gente precisa
avançar ea gente precisa é é com juntar
reestruturar essa representação
qual o papel da universidade nisso tudo
qual é a universidade é grande produtora
de conhecimento e na universidade que se
testam e que se de certa maneira é se
deslocam os conhecimentos que são
participe a partir do que a gente vai
restabelecer as bases da nossa sociedade
a universidade tem o dever de recolocar
questões e the edge instituir padrões
opressores
então é importante que a universidade
abrigue né hoje o segmento lgbt de forma
geral as pessoas trans e mais do que
hoje na universidade no nos últimos anos
né o projeto original da universidade
que era um projecto emancipador era o
projeto de constante é a articulação de
saberes e de constante testagem dos
padrões e parâmetros de verdade isso se
perdeu ao longo da história hoje a
universidade há algum tempo é com um
projeto de dominação imediata da
natureza de instrumentalização do
conhecimento
a universidade é basicamente formadora
de técnicos ea gente perde um pouco o
horizonte crítico da universidade
horizonte com mestrado tório que deveria
ser a pedra basilar do que se produz
aqui dentro
então não adianta a gente dizer que é
calle como produtor ou eu como
professora formados na universidade é
cumprimos ou sites fizemos a o papel de
inclusão que a sociedade deveria cumprir
em relação ao segmento e sexual
cabe à universidade é e é um desafio não
só para o segmento é transexual para o
as fileiras dos dados do segmento
transexuais mas em relação à toa
os segmentos oprimidos da nossa
sociedade cabe à universidade lançar
desafios que desloca em que três tornem
os padrões é que o combate do que a
sociedade em quadra ea forma de
estereótipos que a sociedade que é o é o
papel eo lugar onde o bloco onde a
universidade está enxerga esses
segmentos marginalizados e oprimidos ao
longo da história como lançando é um
pólo eu quero ver qual rj por exemplo
lançar um fórum permanente de discussão
e promoção da equidade da população
trans
eu quero que eu quero entrar na
universidade eu quero entrar na hoje eu
sou professora do cap da ufrj eu quero
entrar lá e eu quero não ser é passar
vel' do ponto de vista de igual a todas
aquelas professoras que estão na lista
porque porque para chegar ali e eu tive
de me mutilar tanto eu tive de deixar
tantas coisas eu tive de deixar tantas
coisas nesse caminho a gente quando é um
segmento prime de marginalizado
a gente se perde tanto a gente pede
tanto que não nos satisfaz chegar a um
espaço né que dito privilegiados em que
aquele espaço seja de certa maneira
transformado transtornado reorganizado
pela nossa experiência eu quero ser ali
e acho que o caio também todos nós
transexuais esse desafio e mais né de
forma maior todos os segmentos oprimidos
e marginalizados queremos estar ali
porque marcamos aquele espaço com a
nossa identidade com a afirmação da
nossa identidade com a afirmação do que
nos constitui eu não quero mais ter uma
professorinha que chega ali e da o
conteúdo como todas as outras e que
talvez muito depois por algum sinal o
aluno perceba que eu sou uma mulher
transexual eu quero estar ali como uma
mulher transexual e quero que aquilo
seja assumido pelo espaço da
universidade
o desafio acho que a universidade que eu
quero é a universidade que não mais é o
big todos aqueles que portam a diferença
é a diferença construída para a opressão
eu não quero mais uma universidade que
nos constrange a regra
o cara essa diferença e nos aproxima de
um padrão eu quero uma universidade uma
ufrj e consiga nos levar a um lugar de
pleno é de constante é desafio e um
lugar de constante edis formulação dos
padrões né eu sei que vai sempre
desconstituir tudo que nos oprime e que
nos constrange a formatação única e aí o
desafio é esse não é uma universidade
que se lance pense como eu vou é não
obrigar travesti suburbana eu sempre
digo eu sou uma travesti suburbana nunca
deixei de ser é porque eu sou doutoranda
e literatura que eu deixei de ser uma
travesti suburbana
mas as marcas o tudo que eu tive de
deixar da minha vivência como travesti
suburbana pra trás pra ocupar o espaço
né e o espaço é licenciado pela
sociedade um espaço é de certa maneira
de empoderamento além de empoderamento
mais um espaço de sanção de cidadania
tudo que eu tive de deixar pra trás
minha caro no início achava maravilhoso
né eu deixei que as marcas nunca vamos
deixar e não é bom que deixamos eu sou
uma mulher transexual negra suburbana e
eu não quero que isso fique para trás
que as experiências pregressos que eu
tive e que me constitui antes de entrar
na universidade estejam pra é de sejam
deixadas para trás pra que eu possa
ocupar determinado espaço e são essas
experiências e essas marcas como mulher
transexual negra e pobre eu vou levar
para os espaços institucionais e é ali
que a gente vai é ea partir daí é da
função dessa dessa identidade cheia de
enfim em percursos que vai transformar
aquele espaço institucional e acho que a
universidade precisa promover esses
esses tensionamentos e compadres
permanentes de discussão de gênero de
discussão de orientação sexual
neco é necessidade de por que na hora eu
venho da faculdade de letras da letra
isso é problemático mas é muito menos do
que em outro espaço da liberdade
e eu quero que a universidade espaços em
que isso não seja é sequer pensado nele
sequer cotidiano sequer problematizado
que a universidade promove nesses
espaços deste debate que leve
professores transexuais alunos
estrangeiros para esses lugares e ali
constitui um fórum permanente de
discussão constitui essa problematização
que crie núcleo de pesquisa é que sejam
comprometidos com a emancipação de
cimento e que passa esse percurso para
que a universidade não seja mais o lugar
dos recalls não é bom sermos os
transgêneros que conseguiram entrar na
sociedade que não foi modificada
essencialmente é bom que sejamos nós com
todas as marcas que nos constituem é que
chegamos num lugar porque este lugar foi
essencialmente transformado e é esse
desafio da ufrj que nós queremos é isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]